hello everybody today I'm going to just
talk about building your portfolio new
way of doing this thing because like
maybe you just tried to build your
portfolio and couldn't find a job or
couldn't find a
internships and I was same positions as
you like I couldn't find internships I
couldn't find jobs and then I did some
stuff differently and then
find two or three times
my jobs from getting a message from
LinkedIn so my presentation will be all
about this thing and of course with open
source contribution or we can say
building your projects publicly is open
source thing and yeah let's get started
the agenda will
Bei and why I am here and then all way
of doing building your portfolio
and then I'm just going to talk about
purple cost uh paradigma and then
definitely going to talk about
authenticity authenticity is your key
for building a portfolio and finding a
job okay who am I I'm actually uh and
not drop outs y student because I don't
like school and my school is extended
one year and I'm still doing uh uh doing
my undergraduate degree and right now
I'm so excited about llms and how large
language models are changing the world
and changing our daily life and also
people are saying that I'm I'm I'm a
good connector I'm a good communicator
and that's why I'm also frankly
authentic about community building and
Dev stuff developer relations and and
also I think I'm a slow learner but more
like a concentrated or smart learner and
then last but not least on a Relentless
journey of growth I love growth and I
hate fixed
mindset okay so as agenda say the first
thing is we are going to talk about old
way of doing finding jobs building your
portfolio actually I have some notes in
here I'm just say that right now is
maybe you you see or you saw or like
you're aware of that right now it's
really when you're applying for a
position applying for a job your CV is
not effective enough like most of the
time if if you're not uh looking for a
uh for a corporated business or other
stuff your CV will be like
nothing because right now most people
are care about your social presence your
projects your open source projects and
then your post on the LinkedIn I I think
like your LinkedIn profile or GitHub
profile is like better than your CV and
also so during this talk I'm just going
to talk about finding a job or building
your portfolio but at the same time just
uh remember that you cannot you cannot
make things Rush when you're finding a
job because like there there are a lot
of quote for this one uh like just find
your jobs when you're in job like when
you have job and that's really important
and the other thing is like when you're
uh connecting with other people when
you're asking something you just don't
take more energy than you give to the
person because like most of the time
like uh I'm just sending a lot of
messages on the LinkedIn to the people
to for having a talk and I
should I think like it's it's my
uh how can I say it's my thing about
like I have to give more than I take and
then can ask
questions and that's it anyway Let's uh
back into the uh presentation so I'm
going to just talk about fixed mindsets
most of the people think about like if I
have degree it will be easier for me to
job yes it is but why you are not uh why
you not building your portfolio right
now not after school right now and then
most of the people are thinking about
like
relatives uh is is uh is better way to
find a job because like when you have a
connection in a company uh it it will be
easier for you yes it will be easier but
it's not the old thing and also most of
the people are doing these projects that
are not fun or that that are not
interested for themselves and like if if
you have a chance to work on your hobby
project with your hobbies
like basketball football or other stuff
it will be I think it will be best for
you to having a fun and like stacking
your
motivators and yeah and all of these
fixed mindset lead to this like crying
with your resume that you're you cannot
find a job because you are doing
something
differently and I'm just going to talk
about purple Cs and
purple cow is a thing that when I
reading kort's book I guess yes when
when I read in neport books that become
so good they can ignore
you uh he's he was he was just talking
about purple cows and like imagine
you're always going to from town to city
and beside the road beside the road
there are a lot of cows like black cows
gray cows White
calls and then like you're not aware
every time because they they are always
there but when you have some kind of
purple CS beside the street beside the
road you're just going to say wow just
gonna uh take your phone and take a
picture of purple cow and just GNA share
or if there are other people like beside
you you're just gonna say wow look at
the purple car and yeah that's the
thing and it's actually it's a marketing
Paradigm that being that is all about
being remarkable and I'm just gonna ask
you a question about like do you believe
that you own a purple C that make things
differently for
you
okay
and I was just I just want to think you
about purple cows and if you have a
purple cow anyway let's go and the
purple CS is all about being 100%
remarkable so how how can you being be
remarkable in this world like in this
big world because there are Elm mask
there are like other crazy people of
remarkable
people so remarkable is not all about
quality but but more than uniqueness
okay quality is always effect the
remarkable but you have to be unique
like
so every people in the data science
field somehow build some kind of
projects portfolio projects with Titanic
data set
right and like it's not remarkable
because there is no uniqueness but if
you have some kind of project with with
your hobby like basketball or like with
your hobby of G gym workout or those
kind of stuff building some kind of data
science project with uh basketball data
set or like football data set with
unique data set it's going to definitely
make you more unique from the other
people and you can just stand out from
other candidates when you're applying
for a
position and also
I I don't have cover video but it's it's
really crazy idea because I just saw on
the LinkedIn some time ago that somebody
just build a video about him about
herself and her projects not just uh CV
you know I think it's definitely be
remarkable when you send a cover video
to somebody and if you make it like
personal or like for for the company
customized for cover video it's going to
definitely be make you remarkable from
other
candidates and you have to sustain it
this remarkableness
and how can you do that like keep doing
uni stuff with your hobbies with your
interests and you you I I think like
right now the best thing is like share
what you learn on the LinkedIn and show
up every day like
I'm not seeing literally every day but
you have to show up sometime some period
of time in the
Linkin and just share what you learned
and
yeah and these are some small bets that
I think it's really useful for you to
build
your uh build your open source portfolio
or like build build your own uh
portfolio so there is uh new paradigma
about be chip share and I just learn it
from AI make space and why I love it
because you are building shipping and
sharing so what what you you can build
is Hobby projects so start with your
interest start with your hobbies that
you already have like if your hobbies is
all about flowers make some projects
about flowers it will be definitely make
you stand out from other people
and
then I think like building relationships
with networking okay I say that uh some
people are just thinking about like
being
relatives not having relatives in the
company is making easier for them to
find a job you have to build your
relationships and networking but at the
same time you have to build your own
heart skills like programming coding
building your projects with as I said
hobby projects and then uh and then you
can ask some other people for help when
you're finding jobs but don't forget
about like you have to give more than
what you take and then shipping is all
about okay you can ship or make live of
your uh projects with small prototypes
and then hackaton are definitely great
way to ship or build your uh small
products or like small projects and also
I'm I'm doing the heatons like the last
weekend we did some kind of projects and
we got the first
place and I'm still doing the hackaton
and I love doing projects about llms in
the
heatons and also sharing so you you can
share with your technical writing you
can write on the medium if you want to
have uh your website you can build your
own website I did both of them like I
wrote some uh blog post on the medium I
wrote some blog post about on my own
website and also okay so another
paradigma is all about uh new way of
writing so people people are always
thinking about like writing on their own
website is better but at the same time
you have to post on the uh strong uh
strong social media places right like
LinkedIn Twitter or like I think GitHub
is not a good example but some other
places like poly workg Etc and I think
like sharing blog post or like what you
wrote down on the blog post on the
LinkedIn post I think it's it's it will
be make easier for you to reach out
other people and building public showing
what you learned and also you can shoot
videos always
like I think like when you when things
came to the sharing like you built your
project you built your uh projects with
hackaton small prototypes hobby project
Etc and then when it comes to sharing
it's always part because like there are
a lot of fears like fear of other people
judgment fear of other people thinking
fear of like there are a lot of fears so
what you can do is just just do it it's
it's a great
uh great recommendation like just do it
and may maybe you can ask somebody when
you're are sharing your first post you
can ask for feedbacks about your first
post or if it's really hard you can
always ask me about feedback for your
post for your videos for your blog post
everything you can ask
feedbacks for uh to the people about
your uh what you are
sharing okay uh the another thing is
authenticity I think so okay
being stand out is not meaning of like
building crazy projects building your
you know hack project Etc but it's more
about you have everybody H everybody all
already a purple C because there's
authenticity that cannot that other
people cannot compete with you because
you are you you have your own view you
have your own
perspective uh own thoughts and but why
we are great CA right now because system
it's really hard for other people other
management people to manage you when
everybody has like their individual uh
views individual perspective so you have
to see some things at a way that people
can manage you that's that's why system
is makes us uh great C
but these are like three of my
principles create more than consume grow
more more than fixed give more than take
if you apply this three uh three
principles in your life you can get gain
regain of your
publicness and you can take your
authenticity and it's it will be really
easier for you to find a job uh and
build your
portfolio I think that's it I I hope
this uh this meeting this session will
be remarkable for you to to to connect
with me on the LinkedIn connect with me
on the Twitter or other places
anywhere what you want and and and
that's it if you have any questions I
can take questions
right hi M um thanks a lot for the for
the great talk I love the the concept of
giving um as well as as taking when
interacting with others um do you have
any any examples you know I can I can
think of example from my own life of
what what I can cont but do do you have
any ex any other examples that you can
share with us yeah okay
so when I'm asking some people about
having a meeting with them I'm just
asking about like I know we are really
busy but I can bring my own authentic uh
perspective of seeing the llms and my
own thoughts about deterministic
thoughts about llms and that's just it
you you don't have to give
like I don't know I don't know other
examples but I think bringing your own
uh own perspective is
already uh bigger than what you are
taking from other
people yeah yeah
absolutely and like as I say when I'm
sending a message to other people
personalized invitation is always works
for me I think
some of them are not working but most of
the time they're
working and also as I say you just have
to uh say
that uh I know you are really busy or
like but maybe we can do this meeting
next week or like two weeks later or
like next month you can just postpone it
because like the other people will
always be uh busier or I don't know
maybe you know uh busier or like have a
lot of things on on their plate and if
you ask like another month or like I can
pink you like next month or like NE
after two weeks it always works just do
it yeah abely and if you never try you
if you don't ask you never know yeah
yeah yeah yeah definitely and also right
now I'm reading this book about 4our
work week
and there's concept about like like Tim
FIS is just giving uh some kind of
challenge to the students about try to
reach out some like remarkable persons
or like unreachable persons like CEOs
CTO and like because of people are not
sending emails they cannot reach but
other people just try to send emails
like twice twice a week or something
like that and then just got the meeting
that's it because like because nobody is
trying this stuff you
know and if you try it you can maybe
reach
it thank you up for the question by the
way okay okay I I have another question
from eron what heatons do you recommend
participating in the data analytics or
AI
so right now I I have I'm just following
three two places when it comes to
heatons laab Ai and the other one is Dev
post both of these uh places have great
hackaton for llms AI or data and data
science or analytics yeah I think just
two place like Labb AI I think that
they're doing
like two hackaton a week twice a week uh
or something like that
and that's crazy and also always you can
look at uh some other projects some
other uh public projects because they
they they have all the galleries of
projects in the heatons and you can take
inspiration inspiration from these
projects when you are building your own
project and
yeah
okay any other
questions yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah of
course and also I saw that
aaria on
the we have one raised hand yeah sorry I
actually joined the the session late so
I just wanted to ask you few questions
like simple questions actually I am not
that great at coding like I know Python
and SQL but people who contribu open
source they have some very big profiles
on like Twitter GitHub that they have
done big big projects and then even they
get jobs also through open source so can
you guide for someone like us who are
not that good in coding but if we want
to contribute something what should we
do like I mean MH I think like okay I
can just uh share you on
here let's do it like beginner guide of
contribution
contribution okay I I think like there
are a lot of blog post of how we can
contribute or like there are a lot of
videos about it
and I think the the key thing when
you're contributing is good first issues
just just look at the good first issues
and some companies some open source
companies has already some kind of
mentorship for contribution or like you
can ask any questions that you want in
in the places like Discord communities
or like slack communities of these open
source
projects and I I think they're going to
definitely like help you because I think
their job is like Community managers is
job is makes you uh easier to contribute
on their
projects
yeah I I think I I answered your
question yes and another question I had
is like I just checked a linked you have
done a lot like so how to like any guide
for making good ml any like road map for
making good ml projects because like
nowadays lot of things are coming up in
Market like llms and like there are
various llms so first we had a just a
chat GPT but now if you see we have even
llm so it infrastructure to like on
Twitter I could see those
postm yeah so I think best thing to
learn is okay I learned a lot from other
people when when I'm joining the
hackathon and because some some other
people are doing great Pro programming
like clean code and those other
principles of like uh system design Etc
and you can just
uh participate in the hackaton and you
can find teammates that are really hard
coders because because I'm also not
great at
coding uh and then you can learn from
other people like when you are having a
project with them on the on the hackaton
and I I think that's that's a great
way
and and yeah I think that is the answer
and also you can like find videos or
like find blog post about on on the on
the Web Internet you
know how to start contribution to open
source project okay so there are like if
llm open source
projects or which is what I'm interested
in right
now let's do quick thing and
also can can I take like 10 minutes or
something like that
Barbara for just showing yeah we still
have we still have few minutes so if you
want to share something I think this
might be a good good moment uh folks for
those of you that have other plans we're
we're past the time but the session is
still recorded you're welcome to hang
around and um and continue with the
session otherwise you will be able to
have the access to recording
afterward yeah thank you
Barbara okay
yeah so these are the open source
LMS yeah I think this R redit post there
are some crazy tools like L chain llama
index and other stuff and also another
thing is like you you don't need to have
some kind of hard skills of like
programming when you're are contributing
you can contribute with OP like with
documentations with with other stuff
with non-technical stuff and then after
some time you can turn out to be become
more like a hard skill contributor you
can contribute if you if you have
experience with the
documentations and then it it will be
easier for you to contribute on the on
the code
base and
yeah thank you so for your valuable
suggestions I will apply them in my
learning MH and also as probably CA sent
in the chat there are like places all or
like other places to find open source in
internships and yeah that that's a great
way to like contribute open source
and doing your internship at the same
time killing two birds with one stone
yeah
I'm just going to stop my share
by and also after this meeting uh after
this session I will I I will be on the
air
meet I think there is uh there's a place
for for the mentorship that we can have
talk one by one or like I maybe I can
incre I don't know but maybe I can
increase the people on on the a meet I
don't
know and yeah that's it